one of the things you will frequently do
in the first years of your career both
in Professional Services in Consulting
and also in the corporate word is
writing meeting minutes so writing and
distributing notes after important
meetings so in this video today I want
to share some crucial advice on how to
write and structure meeting minutes in
the style of large consulting firms such
as McKenzie BCG and Bane so welcome to
New coffee break here on my channel from
learning the place where I want to help
you to succeed in the first years of
your career so let's get started I
prepared for you a helpful template
based on a document that I frequently
use to take meeting minutes in my time
in Consulting if you want to follow
along pause the video access the video
description to get the link and download
the template for free let's start with a
header of the meeting minutes template
here I'd recommend you to clearly
mention what type of meeting it is and
also mention that this is now the
meeting minutes that you would be
currently looking at now the next
section here let's mention the date the
location and the participants so when
did the meeting take place where did it
happen so is it an online meeting or was
there any specific meeting room any
specific meeting location and then let's
also mention participants so for more
important meetings maybe board meetings
it's even legally required to have a
clear list of attends in the meeting
minutes so make sure that this included
for you as well and then I'd recommend
you to take the minutes with a simple
structure and here you will write down
all the action items right so this is
not intended to be used as you writing
down every single thing that someone
might have said this is usually not how
you write meeting minutes but instead
you focus on three main points three
main items that you want to write down
first insites second tasks third
decisions so let's start with the first
in insights so this is a piece of
insight that some person shared in the
meeting usually you're not repeating
things which already part of the meeting
document anyways but if someone is
sharing a point then is getting picked
up on in the meeting that then is
getting discussed in the meeting you can
write this down here as an Insight so to
some extent this might be a little bit
subjective what exactly you write down
here make sure that these points are
relevant so if you're filling out this
template during a meeting you are
writing down here the correct type of
item that you're referring to here for
instance I for inside you're writing
down now the inside here into the cell
and then you also you're mentioning who
is the responsible person or the owner
in this example who shared the Insight
in the meeting first type of items
second types tasks so these are the
to-dos right so these are things that
someone now is asked to you with the
letter t here for instance someone is
asked to investigate the drivers of the
cost per lead increase and potential
measures to reduce the cost to
historical averages until the next
hearing committee here now you can write
down who's supposed to do this the
responsible person Lisa in this example
next d a decision so the people meeting
have made a certain decision let's
imagine that this is a steering
committee maybe the board comes together
and here this was about a budget
approval that was decided in this
meeting for decisions you might also
want to write down whether they are
unanimous or whether some were in favor
or against it to take note of that as
well and now over time during the
meeting you can fill out add additional
points here to the sheet based on the
information that we just discussed and
then at the end of the meeting you will
send an email to all the people
attending the meeting adding the Excel
table here with the meeting minutes and
then ask everyone to review it and
potential let you know whether anyone
feels like he or she has been
misrepresented if this is a recurring
series of meetings as it's usually the
case with for inst instance steering
committees or board meetings you might
want to copy this tab several times for
every meeting that is taking place then
you can just change here the date for
the respective meeting and then also
keep always the meeting minutes of Prior
dates in here as a history for future
reference so whenever I use the
structure like this to write down
meeting minutes as a more Junior
consultant maybe also more senior one I
usually always got very positive
feedback I do hope that this template
helps you as well to write your meeting
minutes again you find it as a free
download in the video description feel
free to check it out if you want to
learn more about taking notes I will
link above another video I did on note
taking techniques but if you are really
serious to develop yourself
professionally I recently created my new
Communications and slide Writing Academy
this is the firm learning educational
Flagship offering if you're interested
to transform your career and learn
essential skills else Tau and firm
McKenzie BCG and Bane feel free to check
it out Link in the video description and
now I'd love to hear from you do you
have any tips you'd like to add on
meeting minutes feel free to leave a
comment if you took any value at all out
of this video please destroy the like
button and smash subscribe as well for
the YouTube algorithm my name is Hinrich
I release weekly videos here on the
channel see you again soon big thanks to
all the members of the channel thank you
so much for your support until next week